just security of your applications keep
you awake at night stay tuned to learn
how anthems can help hi I'm Priyanka and
welcome to enthuse 101 each of your
customers implicitly trusts you with
their data and keeping it secure is your
top priority in this video let's learn
more about how endows makes it easier to
secure your applications as key
technologies like containers and micro
services become more commonplace
traditional security models are no
longer sufficient security posture is
fragmented based on parameters like your
platform do you run on premises or in
cloud or both your workloads are you
running your VMs or containers or both
your services are deregulated or
sensitive workloads or public facing
information some problems with older
methods are lack of visibility into what
is happening on your network lack of
consistency in terms of controls or
policies enabling a zero trust security
posture can help you solve these issues
and also modernize your security for
hybrid and multi cloud deployments and
and those equips you with all you need
to implement a zero trust model but
first what is your trust
it is a security principle that is based
on implementing security controls at
every single layer of your stack and
with every interaction or engagement
often considered as defense-in-depth
this means you start with secure
bootstrapping at every node and in every
cluster next you secure the network not
just at the perimeter and the edge but
by effectively segmenting your
deployment and securing the network for
each service then you secure access be
it your infrastructure your application
or the underlying data you also secure
your deployments and rollouts by making
sure both your code and your
configuration are only rolled out when
trusted and validate it and finally you
can't protect against what you cannot
see so you need better observability to
enforce compliance and quickly spot
threats now let's see why you need these
and how Antos helps you accomplish these
first secure bootstrapping this is
essential because any issues here can
quickly affect multiple services shared
in your infrastructure google cloud
provides you with features such as
shielded VMs container optimized oasis
to reduce your risk surface and
encryption at rest to prevent
unauthorized access you also have access
to hardening guides to help you
incorporate best practices on-premises
next let's talk about securing your
network in such a way that you are
protecting all your diverse workloads
this is where you can protect against
exfiltration of your data either
maliciously or unintentionally to
uncontrolled environments unauthorized
access from the internet using either
stolen credentials or by exploiting miss
configurations and remote code execution
attacked like SS RF google cloud
provides you with everything you need to
protect both your public facing apps and
to seal your perimeter using products
like cloud armor and those chi-chi's
security controls and vbc service
controls it is also essential to secure
access this helps you protect against
unauthorized access using stolen
credentials compromised code in your
deployments through privilege
escalations or unpatched vulnerabilities
malicious insiders with access to
internal endpoints and any underlying
network compromises and those helps you
implement these controls using a
combination of features such as anther
service mesh to implement authentication
authorization and encryption between
your services and IEP to implement
granular access controls we spoke about
securing your deployments and rollouts
this is essential to reduce trust on a
single deployer or admin and those
provides you with capabilities such as
binary authorization to ensure that your
workloads are trusted and validated
before they can make it into your
deployment preventing any untrusted code
from running there and when it comes to
your configurations and those config
management helps you establish a trusted
workflow including reviews and
approvals for any configuration changes
that can impact your deployments this
way you can manage your policy as code
in addition monitoring is not only key
to quickly identifying threads but also
to maintain detailed audit logs and
records for compliance and those gives
you access to detailed audit logs for
your code your configurations and your
network so today we saw that anthos and
Google cloud give you everything you
need to deploy a zero trust model for
your applications it gives you the
ability to deploy and maintain a
security posture that is consistent
across environments policy-driven
optimized for cloud native applications
application and user context aware try
on those for yourself and get started on
your journey to zero trust security
following the links below and for more
anthos content don't forget to subscribe
and follow the entire anthems one on one
playlist
[Music]